So, we are beginning volume 16, and we begin at July the 23rd, 1923, and for a few messages
we're going to be talking about the divine will.
Louisa said, "I was abandoning all of myself in the holy divine will, according to my usual
way, and my sweet Jesus made himself seen coming towards me in order to receive me in
his most holy will."
She actually sees him coming to absorb her into himself.
He said, "My daughter, my will is in continuous encounter with the human will."
That's a very important statement.
And as the human will encounters mine, it receives light, sanctity, and strength which
my will contains.
So the more we encounter the divine will, the more we receive light, sanctity and strength.
My will, Jesus said, is in the continuous act of giving itself to souls in order to give
the soul the life of heaven in advance.
In other words, living in the divine will is actually living the life of the blessed down
here on the earth.
If she receives me, notice the if clause, she the soul remains with this celestial life.
We have divine life.
But if in every act they do, souls do not receive this supreme volition, which is all
intent for their good on making them happy, strong, holy, divine, and as though transformed
into a dawn of celestial light, if they don't, they remain with their human will alone, which
renders them weak, miserable, muddy and surrounds them with vile passions such as to arouse
pity.
Now, you're given both examples there with extraordinary comparison because by volume
16, if we haven't shifted, the Lord has got to put a balm on dress and what he's trying
to say.
This message is not for people living different kinds of spiritual lives.
This is for people living in the divine will and you don't say this to anybody else.
I think that's important to say that.
You don't make a comparison with this spirituality and other spiritualities.
It's very different because we're dealing with the crown of all spirituality and the
other spiritualities are all preparation for this.
So it's at this level that if you don't cooperate with the divine will, that in the eyes of
the Lord, it's just horrendous because he's ready to give us absolutely his highest and
his best.
Don't you see how many souls dragged themselves along?
Look at that expression because of their weakness in being unable to conquer themselves to do
good.
Now, the worst of all failures in life is not to conquer yourself.
We have had Alexander the Great conquering the whole of the Middle East.
We were dealing with that today in our scripture class.
We didn't conquer himself and he died an unconquered person at the age of 32, which
I think is awfully crazy.
So I want to give you Jeremiah 1617 for that.
Jeremiah 1617.
So how many souls dragged themselves along because of their weakness in being unable to
conquer themselves to do good?
Others who don't know how to dominate themselves.
So there you have the lack of self-control pointed out.
Others who are in constant like reads, now do you remember Matthew 725 by their fruits
you will know them?
And you also have Jesus, I forgot to write this one down, saying that John the Baptist
was not like a read in the wind, he was stable, okay?
So these people are like reads blowing in the wind.
Others who don't know how to pray without a thousand distractions, that means that their
mind is not fixed on the Lord, okay?
And others are always discontent.
So if we're discontent, we are certainly not surrendered to the divine will.
So the Lord is giving us major discernment here and maybe you could put a heading there
for yourself, major discernment.
In other words, he's telling you to take the thermometer and see just how you're doing
in your journey into divine will.
Others who seem to even born to do evil.
These are all souls who do not encounter my will in all of their things.
Now according to these writings, your things are thoughts, words, deeds, actions, movement
steps.
They're all your things.
Yet my will is there for all because you wouldn't exist without it.
And because they shun the divine will, they do not receive the good which the divine will
contains, and this is a just pain for one who wants to live of her own will involving
herself in all kinds of miseries.
Now the Lord says that the misery you have in staying at the level of the human will,
when you know that there's a higher level you can go to, that it's a just misery.
I think that's interesting, it's a just pain.
However, this will of mine, which they did not want, that's the souls we've just been
talking about, they didn't want to encounter in life.
When the divine will would have given them many goods for as many times as they would
encounter it, they will encounter the divine will in death.
Giving them as many pains for as many times as they shunned it, ouch.
In other words, if you absolutely refuse to encounter the divine will and let it give
you all the life and the good during lifetime, you have to face it in death anyway.
Because by shunning the divine will, they have rendered themselves guilty and they've stained
themselves and covered themselves with mud.
Now, several times in the early volumes up to about I would be thinking volume eight
or nine, Jesus had to warn Louisa that she wasn't considering what he was doing seriously
enough and that if she pulled away from him, that it would actually be serious sin and
he would actually stop the relationship she had.
In fact, I think it's in volume nine or ten, he said to her, I would reduce you back to
where you were at the beginning, you'd get out of that bed and nobody would ever know
you'd sat there.
He said, I'll just restore your normal health, but you'll have none of the graces, none
of the gifts, but you'll have all the judgment that goes with rejecting this incredible gift.
And it was the one time when he gave her a very severe wake up call because she was
very severely attempted at the time.
And so here we're being given a wake up call that if we don't deal with and cooperate with
the divine will in all our dealings during life, you'll have to deal with them eventually.
So he says, it's just that they receive a pain and as many painful encounters form
for them, for as many times as they've not encountered my will upon the earth.
But these painful encounters will be without merits, without new gains, as would have happened
if they had encountered my will.
So if they have to encounter it after death, there's no merit after death.
It's only during your lifetime you're allowed to merit.
Okay.
So he said, how many moons of sorrow, I think there shouldn't be an S there, come from
the prisons of purgatory, I would say prison without the S again, they love putting everything
into the plural.
How many shouts of desperation can be heard from hell because my will was not encountered
on the earth.
Now encountered means that you enter into communion with the divine will and you allow
the divine will to do the work that he wants to do in us.
Therefore my daughter, may your first act be to encounter my will, may your first thought
and heartbeat be to encounter the eternal heartbeat of my will that you may receive all
of my love.
Now the first act is both the first act in the morning and the very first thing you do
anytime you turn to God, the very first thing.
So we've trained ourselves that the first thing you do is fuse in the divine will.
So you enter into the divine will and then any prayer you want after that.
Try to make continuous encounters in everything.
This is actually very important and the Lord has, he has repeated this message a number
of times since volume 12 and that is that many people think it's enough to say their
Pervenient act in the morning and then maybe once or twice during the day they just repeat
another one but he says no, continuously enter into the divine will and that is that you are
consciously entering into the divine will at every moment, okay.
So try to make continuous encounters in everything that you may be transformed in my will and
I in yours.
That's John 14, 20 to 21, you and me and I in you.
So as to dispose yourself to make the final encounter with my will at your last hour.
So the surrender we make to the divine will in our last breath should be your PhD.
It shouldn't be your first practice and it shouldn't be oh by the way I better do this.
You know, well I'm dying so I better do this.
Some people only make a surrender in their dying but that's not enough.
They will be saved but it's not enough.
In this way he said you will have no painful encounter after that, okay.
So July the 24th, 1923 and here we get a very, very important statement by Jesus that the
divine will contains the whole of the divine being.
That's why refusing it is very, very serious.
Louisa said I was feeling very oppressed because of the privation of my beloved Jesus.
I was saying to myself everything is over for me.
As much as I look for him he doesn't come, what torture, what martyrdom.
But while I was thinking of this my adorable Jesus made himself seen as crucified, laying
himself over my poor person.
The two of them are one and she sees everything visually.
She's not an intellectual person.
If she was an intellectual person the Lord would give her messages and ideas.
But because she's a visual person and not an intellectual, the Lord teaches her through
visual images.
You know there are two types of people spiritually and we literally call them intellectuals and
I forget what we call the other one but it means people who, imaginative, that's it.
One group are called intellectuals and the other group are called imaginatives.
The intellectuals operate according to ideas and the imaginatives need pictures.
But this very same revelation can be given either way.
Very often the intellectuals think that the imaginatives are much lower than them because
they're intellect is obviously higher according to themselves.
But in actual fact when you look at what was revealed to Louisa it was the highest level
of mystical theology and the intellectuals have to really work on this to work out what's
actually being said.
So the fact that it comes to you as one or the other doesn't actually matter because
God has allowed these two types to develop.
So it's the reason why Louisa sees everything in images and pictures.
Jesus eventually came, he laid himself over my poor person and a light that came out from
within his adorable forehead.
Now the forehead is considered by everybody to be the wall protecting the intellect.
They always consider the intellect behind your forehead.
And that's why Eastern religions like the Hindus and others put a spot there.
That's their commitment.
And that's why you're told in the book of Revelation that the beast will demand a spot
either on your forehead or on your hand, the mark.
Okay.
The spot on your forehead doesn't have to be physical.
Many people think it is and they think it's this chip, you know, it's going into the hands.
It's not that at all.
The spot on the forehead means what you have given your intellect to and you've got the
three powers of the sword, intellect, memory and the will.
Now what you give your intellect to is the spot on the forehead.
What you give your, what you work for is the spot on your hands and your work for what
you've given yourself to, hence the spot on both places.
And the reason why I'm calling it a spot is that many of these Eastern religions actually
put a spot on the forehead.
And ancient religions did that as well, put a spot actually on the forehead.
So Louisa said that a light came out from within his forehead and he said, "My daughter,
my will contains my whole being."
If you ever call her anything, call her that.
And one who possesses my will within herself possesses me.
More than if she had my continuous presence.
This is very important because in the first four volumes particularly, Louisa was having
apparitions of Jesus every single day and sometimes several times a day.
And she thought the important thing was to actually see him and he had to slowly teach
her that you have him all the time, absolutely fully, if your will is committed to his.
And your will and his will become one.
So you possess God and he possesses you.
That's called union with God.
And union with God is required in the spirituality of the divine will.
In the early volumes, the teaching on getting onto the higher plains is very, very clear.
So once you shift beyond volume 12, the Lord makes it perfectly clear that for someone
to actually live in the divine will 24/7, 365, union with God is required.
So you cannot be somebody further down the line.
You absolutely cannot.
And what you'll find is that if somebody gets to this in the readings, they slip away.
They can no longer tolerate it.
It's not meaningful to them.
Is that okay?
And so my daughter, my will, contains my whole being.
And one who possesses the divine will within herself possesses me.
And they possess me more than if they had my continuous presence.
In fact, my will penetrates everywhere.
Let's say I'm 139, where can I go from your spirit?
Where can I flee from your face?
If I go to the heavens, you are there.
If I go into the depths of Cheryl, you are there.
So my will penetrates everywhere into her innermost fibers.
Now when you're doing the hours of the passion, you will hear Louisa, especially, you know,
she does it in the agony in the garden as well.
But at various times, she will tell you that Jesus was suffering in the very fibers of
his being, in the innermost parts of his being.
So the innermost fibers means everything in you is given.
Okay?
Now that's the fulfillment of Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You shall love the Lord, your God, with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your
mind and with all of your being.
The divine will counts her heartbeats and her thoughts.
The divine will makes itself the life of the most beautiful part of the creature which
courses your spirit, your soul, or interior, from which her external works arise.
You see, and the value of the external works is the value of what's going on in the interior.
On the other hand, which is very Jewish on the one hand and on the other hand, okay?
On the other hand, if my presence does not find my will in the soul, it cannot be the
life of her interior.
So if the divine will is not in union with our will, then our works are just not coming
from that.
You're coming from yourself, okay?
And she remains as though separated from me.
How many souls, after having enjoyed my favors and my presence, because the fullness of my
will, its light, its sanctity, was not in them, see, he's giving discernment here again,
have engulfed themselves in sin again and have taken part in pleasures and have separated
from me, because that divine will, which renders the soul untouchable by any sin, even the
slightest was not in them.
That's 1 John 3, verses 2 to 6.
1 John 3, verses 2 to 6, John says that a person who is truly in union with God cannot
sin.
How do you know Hebrews 12, 14?
Nothing unholy or unworthy can ever enter the presence of God.
So therefore, the purest, the holiest, the greatest works are formed in one who possesses
all the fullness of my will.
So what we do for God depends on the level that the divine will is working in us.
Is that okay?
And what the Lord is doing here now is giving us very, very important discernment, so that
we are able to begin to touch what's actually going on inside of us.
You see, the divine will renders the soul untouchable by any sin, and that is because
God is holy.
That's Leviticus 19 to, "I am holy, you shall be holy, for I am holy," says the Lord.
You remember Exodus 3, verses 1 to 10, where Moses was told to take off your shoes.
This is holy ground.
Remember that?
Exodus 3, verses 1 to 10.
And Moses at that stage was not living in union with God, so he had no right to come closer.
Moses had to go through a lot of purification to get to that stage.
So if we have not put sin out of our lives and have not put self out of our lives, forget
about the divine will has not taken over, simple as that.
So that's number one.
Now number two is, see, in the creature also, her human will has supremacy, you need the
word human there.
Her human will has supremacy.
In other words, that's what's ruling the roost.
So if there is a will, she has life, and if there's no will, she's like the tree, while
having a trunk, branches, and leaves, it has no fruit, okay.
So in the human creature, the will is not the thought, but it gives life to the attitude
of the mind.
It's not the eye, but it gives life to the gaze, because if it has will, the eye wants
to see and wants to know things.
Otherwise, it is the eye has no life.
Now when it says no life here, it doesn't have any reason for operating.
The will is not the word.
Now the first thing is that we're told, the will is not the thought, okay.
Now you're told, secondly, the will is not the word, okay?
But it gives life to each word, it's not the hand, but it gives life to each action.
It's not the step, but it gives life to the step.
It's not love, desire, affection, but it gives life to love, desire, and affection.
And this isn't all.
Through the will, the life, through the will is the life of all the human acts, sorry, though
the will is the life of all the human acts.
Once the creature has performed them, she remains stripped of these acts.
In other words, look at this.
Just look for a second.
There's an action.
It's finished.
It's over.
There's nothing else.
If it's in the divine will, it lasts forever.
If it's only in the human will, it's finished.
As soon as you've done this, it's over.
Okay.
So that's what they're saying here.
Once she has performed them, she remains stripped of these very acts.
Like a tree loaded with its fruit, it's stripped by the hands of the one who picks them.
On the other hand, the gazes she has given, the thoughts she has formed, the words that
she has spoken, the actions that she has performed, they remain as though sealed within her will.
So her hand has operated, but her action does not remain in her hands.
It moves beyond, and who knows where it goes, while in the will, it remains there.
Therefore, everything is written, formed, sealed in the human will.
In other words, as the originator of absolutely everything.
And if it is so with the human will, and only because I cast into it the seed, the likeness
of his divine will, think yourself of what my will must be like within you.
Because then if the divine will is the origin of absolutely everything, all these thoughts,
words, desires, actions, steps and all the rest all have an eternal value and will last
forever.
And so you're being shown the two levels all the time.
And what it must be if the creature allows herself to be possessed by my will.
So the two levels are being made very, very clear to us in those messages.
Is that all right?
So July the 27th, 1923, everything's going to happen to Louisa first in the divine will,
and then afterwards the door is open for the rest of us.
That's July the 27th, 1923.
This morning my sweet Jesus made himself seen in a wonderful way.
He was standing upon my heart, and on it he placed two bars over which he had formed an
arch, and in the middle of the arch he had fixed a little wheel with two ropes, that's
a lot of activity isn't it?
One on the right and the other on the left, and a little bucket hanging from it.
And Jesus all in a hurry would make the little bucket descend into my heart, and then he would
pull it up full of water and pour it out over the world.
Now beside that put John 737 to 39.
If you come and drink out of your own heart will flow fountains of living water for others.
Okay there's plenty left over for others.
He kept drawing and pouring in such a way as to flood the earth.
Now the flooding of the earth is all this intercession and penance and reparation that
Louisa is doing.
It was delightful to see Jesus as though hurrying, dripping with sweat because of the effort
he made in drawing so much water.
I thought to myself how is it that so much water comes out of my heart which is so small?
And when did he put it there?
At least Louisa is very conscious of the fact that the source would be God, not herself.
And blessed Jesus made me understand that all that apparatus was nothing other than his will.
Which with so much goodness had operated upon me.
So this little drawing water from the well is simply an image of the divine will operating
in her.
The waters he was drawing were the sayings and the teachings about his adorable will.
Which he had placed in my heart as though in deposit.
And which more than water, now you see, water is a symbol of both grace and salvation.
And if you know it's a symbol of grace and salvation, then you know what's been going
on flooding the earth.
So he was wanting to water the church pouring in grace and salvation in order to give her
the knowledge of his will.
So that it might be fulfilled as he wants.
So as he wants is the fulfillment of the Our Father, okay.
So I want to give you Hosea 4-6.
And Jeremiah 5-4, now Hosea 4-6 says that without knowledge the people perish.
So all down the centuries the Lord has been pouring more and more and more knowledge into
the church through the saints and the mystics so that the church would never be at a point
where it didn't have the knowledge that he wanted her to have.
5-4.
Then Jesus told me, "My daughter, I did this in the incarnation.
First I deposited in my dear mother all the goods which were needed so that I might descend
from heaven to earth.
And then I incarnated myself forming the deposit of my very life.
From my mother this deposit came out as full of life, as life for all, sorry, it should
be life for all I think.
The same will be with my will.
It's necessary that I make the deposit of the goods, the effects, the tragedies and
the knowledge it contains.
And after I have formed the deposit in you, then will it make its way and give itself
to the other creatures.
So the deposit is in Louisa and then there is as much as we want.
The bank is there for us.
Therefore see everything is prepared, the deposit is almost complete.
There's nothing left but to dispose the first ones in order to make it known.
So the first ones to enter the divine will are the people alive at the same time as Louisa.
First of all the priests like Hannibal de Valencia, the sisters and the priests that
he found the two congregations for.
They are the very first people to pick up the divine will.
So first I need to dispose the first ones in order to make it known that it may remain
so it doesn't remain without its fruit.
So July 30th, 1923, the soul who enters the divine will is the celestial flower.
In other words, really living in the divine will 24, 7, 3, 6, 5, Jesus said is a new baptism,
you begin to live a completely new life.
Now a baptism cuts out all the past as you know and opens up a completely new future.
Now he has said that already in the volumes before this.
So Louisa said I was fusing myself in the holy divine will and my sweet Jesus on coming
told me, my daughter, every time the soul enters into my will to pray, notice me to
do it every time, to pray, to work and to do all the other things.
She receives as many divine colors, one more beautiful than the other.
It depends on whether it's prayer or work or self-denial or reparation or whatever.
He calls that a color like the different colors in the rainbow.
Don't you see how much variety of color and of beauty all nature contains?
These are the shadows of the variety of colors and beauty which my divinity contains because
the whole universe reflects the glory of God.
But when two plants and flowers acquire such variety of colors, to whom did I give the
office to color so many varieties of plants with such varied shades I gave it to the sun.
Its light and its heat contain for quantity and variety of colors such as to embellish
the whole earth.
And if the plant merely exposes itself to the kisses of its light, to the embraces of
its heat, the flower opens up and as though returning its kiss and its embrace, it receives
the shadows of colors and forms the beautiful complexion.
Now what he's trying to say to us here is, the plants only have to expose themselves
and the sun does its work.
Now he's telling us to enter into the divine will, expose ourselves to the divine will
and the divine will do its work.
It isn't difficult.
So the sun symbolizes the divine will and the flower which has been factendated and made
beautiful and everything symbolizes the soul.
So the soul that enters into my will is symbolized by the flower that exposes itself to receive
the kiss and the embrace of the sun in order to receive the various colors that the sun
contains.
And by returning them, she receives the different colors of the divine nature.
So what is happening to us, every single time we fuse in the divine will and we should
do it as often as possible every single day, we are being divinized.
God can only make you like himself.
There isn't another model.
And so he wants to divinize us and have all this going on at the divine level.
So she receives the different colors of the divine nature, the different colors of the
wisdom and the sanctity and the holiness and the purity and all the rest of it of the
divine will.
Truly the soul is the celestial flower which the eternal sun by the breath of its light.
Now I love that expression.
The breath of God is the Holy Spirit.
The light of God is God Himself.
So it's the breath of the Holy Spirit, the Holy Spirit working in us has colored so well
as to perfume heaven and earth and delight the very divinity and the whole celestial
court with her beauty.
The rays of my will empty her of what is human and fill her with what is divine.
It happens every single time, another little bit, another little bit, another little bit
as we watch my garden very slowly, very slowly, another tiny little bit change.
With those it's very slow as well.
We're only able to cope with slow change.
Both of us are not able to cope with very fast change.
So one can see in the soul the beautiful rainbow of my attributes.
That means all the virtues, all the attributes of God, the wisdom, the mercy, the forgiveness,
the justice, the holiness, everything, the purity, everything.
Therefore, my daughter enter often into my will to see it there, fuse as often as you can.
Just write fuse at the side, fuse into the divine will as often as possible, to receive
the shades and the various colors of the likeness of your creator.
So again, to use a completely different image, it's like doing a jigsaw puzzle, and every
time you pick up one of the pieces, that wonderful picture develops.
And the Lord says every time we fuse in His divine will, that wonderful divine image is
developed in us.
So August the first 1923, this is a beautiful one, I love you of God, and it's all over
the place.
This is a very great help to the rounds, this one.
Louisa said I was feeling very afflicted because today, my sun, Jesus, did not rise
over my poor soul.
So she's all in shadows and darkness.
Well, God, what pain to spend one day without the sun, it's always nighttime.
Now, while I was feeling pierced in my soul, I had the good fortune of looking at the starry
sky.
I added the word fortune to make it English.
I had the good fortune at looking at the starry sky, and I said to myself, how can it be
that my sweet Jesus no longer remembers anything?
I love that.
I don't know how the goodness of His heart can bear not letting the sun of His lovable
presence rise.
When He told me that He would not be able to endure without coming to His little daughter,
because the little ones cannot be too long without their father.
I put Saint Therese in the margin, because that's actually a summary of Saint Therese's
testimony, that there was absolutely no way she could be without the Lord at all.
But she did not need the apparitions that Louisa needed.
And Therese used to say that she would keep looking at the clouds until the clouds would
part and she'd see this guy.
And Louisa's in a different place to that, but the two of them know at this very simple
thing that a child can't be without its father.
So many are their needs that the father is forced to be with them and watch over them
and guard them and nourish them.
Now that's the little one, so two Corinthians 12.9.
You'd never think I prepared this, because often the Scriptures only come to me when
I'm actually doing it for you.
You, Corinthians 12.9, my power is at best in weakness, okay.
Does he not remember when he would carry me outside of myself and take me up there, even
under the vault of the heavens in the midst of the celestial fears and strolling together
with him?
Isn't that absolutely incredible?
Do you remember Genesis 3?
Genesis 3?
Not sure if it's verse 8, God walked with Adam in the cool of the day.
Do you remember?
Do you strolling together with him and you also have Proverbs 8, 31?
The Lord delights to be with the children of men.
Strolling together with him, I would impress Maya, I love you on each star and in each
sphere.
Well, that was an advantage over you and me, that she was actually up there doing her rounds
of creation among the stars.
I must have been a lot easier, so I think it's fantastic.
As she said, "I seem to see in each star my I love you," so she's looking at the result
of doing the rounds of creation.
It seems to me that in that littering of light that forms around the stars, they resound
among themselves with my I love you Jesus.
Yet he doesn't listen to it, he doesn't come, he does not let his sun rise, which eclipsing
all the stars with my I love you may make them one with his own.
And so rising again in the midst of the celestial spheres, I impress a new I love you.
That's each time we do the rounds of creation.
We put a new layer.
So there's going to be a whole layer of I love you is from all of us on the whole
of creation.
And apparently every time you say it, it's an indelible mark.
That the way I like to put it for myself is you've written your signature on each one
of the stars.
Some years ago for a birthday gift, it was a significant birthday.
Somebody gave me a certificate in which I could name an actual star, have you seen that?
And the name I gave the star that gave me exactly where it is in the celestial spheres
and everything.
It's now registered in London in the place where they register the names of the stars.
And the name I gave was Aego Amy, that's God's name.
I said your own name is written on one of the stars.
I'm sure his name is written on more than one, do you know what I mean?
But we just don't know that.
But every time you put your I love you on the whole starry heavens, your signature is
on creation.
Which I think is fantastic.
And that's what I call the rounds of creation, my signature on what he has done.
And apparently it means an awful lot to him that you put your signature on, because you
put your signature, it's your agreement that you pay this amount or whatever it is.
Or you'll agree to this arrangement.
And so rising again in the midst of the celestial spheres, I am pressed and you I love you
Jesus.
Oh, please, oh stars, cry out loudly, make my I love you resound.
Now for that you need Sam 19 verses one to six, that all of the stars are crying out
but in a mute language.
To make my I love you resound so that touched, Jesus may come to his little daughter to his
little exiled one, oh Jesus come, give me your hand, let me enter into your holy will
so that I may fill the whole atmosphere, the Asia heavens, the light of the sun, the air,
the sea, everything, everything with my I love you.
Now isn't that a lovely way to fuse at the beginning of the rounds of creation?
Because we always need new ideas how to do things.
And with my kisses.
So that wherever you may be, if you look, you may look at my I love you and at my kisses.
If you hear, you may hear my I love you and the smacking kiss of my kisses.
If you speak and you breathe, you may breathe my I love you and my anguishing kisses.
If you work, my I love you's may flow in your hands, if you walk, if you tread my I love
you and my the roaring of my kisses under my steps, notice the way she's describing kisses
in different ways.
May my I love you be the chain that draws you to me and may my kisses be the powerful
magnet which whether you want it or not may force you to visit the one who cannot live
without you, which he said, who can say all the rest of my nonsense.
No, she says nonsense when she expresses herself as deeply as this.
While I was doing this, she said my adorable Jesus came.
So there she was throwing out all kinds of invitations to him to come.
And all goodness and showing me his heart opened, he said, my daughter, place your head upon
my heart and rest.
That's Sam 62, rest in God my soul, rest in God my soul.
And I'll just give you the Sam because it's repeated several times in the Sam.
I want to give you Matthew 11, 28 to 30, come and rest is Jesus's invitation to us.
Now resting in him is first of all entering into his divine will.
And secondly, entering into the prayer of contemplation, where you enter into that simple
oneness without words, without anything else.
So Sam 62 and Matthew 11, 28 to 30.
So place your head on my heart and rest for you are very tired.
Then we will go around together that I may let you see my I love you that my should have
a capital M according to these writings spread over the whole of creation for you.
So Louisa said, I embraced him and placed my head upon his heart in order to rest.
And I felt an extreme need of this rest.
Then afterwards, as I was outside of myself, but always clasped to his heart, he said,
my daughter to you, who are the first born daughter of my supreme will, I want to make
known how the whole of creation upon the wings of my eternal volition brings my I love you
to the creatures.
And the creatures upon the same wings of my will make it their own.
They should give me the requital of their I love you.
Now there's a lovely wonderful introductory piece to rounds of creation.
So the Lord has his I love you on absolutely everything an hour rounds our our response
to that.
Okay.
And so upon the wings of yet they my daughter to you who are the first born daughter of
my supreme will, I want to make known how the whole of creation upon the wings of my eternal
volition brings my I love you to all of you.
And all of you upon the wings of my divine will, making it your own, should give me the
requital of your I love you.
Look at the Asia sky.
There's no point in it in which my and I love you of mine towards the creature is not impressed.
Each star and the glittering that forms a crown around it are studded with my I love
you's each of the sun's rays extends towards the earth to bring light each drop of light
carries my I love you.
And as the light invades the earth and man looks at it and walks on it my I love you
reaches into his eyes into his mouth into his hands and extends under his feet.
The murmuring of the sea murmurs I love you I love you I love you and all the drops of
water are as many keys which murmuring among themselves form the most beautiful harmonies
of my infinite I love you my infinite I love you is Jeremiah thirty one three I've loved
you with an everlasting love and that's beautiful image the murmuring of the ocean and the plants
the leaves the flowers the fruits have my I love you impressed in them.
So the whole of creation brings to man my repeated I love you's and man how many of
my I love you's does he not have impressed upon his whole being my his thoughts are sealed
by my I love you the beating of his heart that palpatates palpatates in his chest with
its mysterious sound tick tick tick is my I love you it's very interesting wouldn't
it or the home would you it's my and I love you of mine which is never interrupted which
says to him I love you I love you his words are followed by my I love you his movements
his steps and all the rest contain my and I love you of mine and yet in the midst of
so many waves of my love he's unable to elevate himself to requite my love what in gratitude
and how grieved my love is left St. Francis of Assisi at the last month of his life was
seen by one of the monks in ecstasy he already had the stick matter at the time and he was
raised up from the ground and he was shouting the the monk didn't know to whom because he
was on his own on Mount Alverne love is not loved he kept on saying love is not loved
love is not loved okay St. John of the Cross said love can be repaid by love alone but
you know that mere own experience don't you love can be repaid by love alone no other
coinage can be used to repay love if someone wants to give you a material thing instead
of love it actually hurts it doesn't help the material thing given with love is completely
different the value is the love and the example I always give is a little child picking your
favorite rose wrongly and grabbing it and bringing it into and saying mommy are daddy
I love you and showing you the rose then they know it's your favorite rose they don't know
they've just destroyed it and what's invaluable is the spontaneous act of the child and the
fact that that child came without being pushed or pulled or anything else to give you this
act of love every parent knows that's one of their best times isn't that right yeah because
it's the love you can't buy and the child deliberately picked up a symbol that you considered
important to give it to you so the gift is the symbol of the love that's actually behind
it so Jesus is saying the whole of creation is merely a symbol of his love everything that
you can do everything that you can accomplish everything you see around you they're all
the I love yous of the Lord therefore my daughter I have chosen you as daughter of my will so
that as a faithful daughter you may defend the rights of your father my love absolutely
wants the requital of the love of the creature I've put that into the I've put some of the
ideas that are here into that little booklet of the rounds of creation my love absolutely
wants it in my will you will find all my I love yous and you by following them will impress
your I love you within mine now there's something we mightn't think of that we don't just give
him our I love yous we put them inside of his that's like saying you put the tiny thing
into the big thing and so they're lost in him everything is through him with him and in
him and do it for yourself and for all souls oh how content I will be in seeing the love
of the creature fused with mine this is why I give my will into your power so that one
creature defending the rights of my love may requite me for that love which I've given
to the whole of creation okay so August the 5th 1923 Jesus is talking about the two eras
one redemption and the other divine will now he comes back to the same theme many times
and each time he adds another piece to it so when we get to the stage of actually studying
this particular theme you'll realize he builds like a Lego he keeps one piece on one on top
of the other Louisa said I was fusing all of myself in the holy will of God and my sweet
Jesus investing me with a supreme light that's the divine will the supreme light told me my
daughter if my supreme will had not let my human will enter into the divine will my humanity
is holy and pure as it is not as the present tense it doesn't say as it was as it is why
because he's alive in heaven isn't he body and soul as pure and holy as it is could not
have formed the complete redemption it needed to be on the divine level my human will number
one would have lacked all seeingness and therefore it would not have been able to see everyone
number two it would have lacked immensity and would not have been able to embrace all
number three it would have lacked omnipotence and it wouldn't have been able to save everyone
number four it would have lacked eternity and it would not have been able to take everything
to one single point now as we move on you see we're now shifting into the higher volumes
the divine will is going to be called a singularity one single point I'm deliberately using the
term a singularity why because the astrophysicists have discovered that beyond the big bang there
is a singularity they're using all the right language they just can't say g or d but they're
using the right language they've actually gone back to the very beginning it's fascinating
absolutely fascinating everything is one single point and because it's one single point just
not in either past or future in it everything is present that's why you can pray for all
souls past present and future so you take everything as one single point to remedy everything
so the first role in redemption was that of my divine will the second of my humanity look
at the order because all the value of everything is the divine will okay if it wasn't for the
divine will redemption would have been for a few and it also would have been limited in
time because not having the light of the all seeingness which makes one know everyone look
at that know everyone because in the hours of the passion Louisa makes it perfectly clear
that Jesus had each one of us in mind and they had each one of our sins in mind to redeem
every single one of them as she said one by one I find that that absolutely breaks me
off I don't know about you that every single one of them one it wouldn't be so bad if you
did it as one kind of big conglomerate you know to be in one big sweeping brush you get
it all out the door no one by one it's the order and the detail that is absolutely amazing
so he said he wouldn't he wouldn't have had the all seeing list that makes one know everyone
I could not have extended myself to all he said so in order to form redemption I did
nothing other than open the doors of the divine will to my humanity okay and this is of course
what we have to do as well we have to imitate him he's the model doors which the first man
had closed with of course his act of rebellion and giving my humanity free field in other
words God had freedom to do everything I let it operate the redemption within the very
bosom of the supreme will so all the redemption was done at the higher plane this is why if
you look at the crucifixion of Jesus from a purely human point of view it is ludicrous
and you can understand the chief priests and everything mocking him and deriving him because
as far as they're concerned this man they knew he had power they knew he could raise
the dead they knew he could walk on water they knew all of this so what on earth was
he doing up there and that's why they they kept saying come down from the cross and we
will believe in you and so since they were only looking at it from a human level what
they were looking at made no sense and louisa got the extraordinary grace to see the passion
from within and to see it from the divine level and every single iota makes sense absolutely
every dot and comma there's not an extra one everything makes sense but only on the
divine plane so from that time on no one else has entered my divine volition that's
john 14 12 to be able to operate as the owner now as the owner is if the divine will possesses
you and you possess it you're the owner to realize what we're saying you're the owner
of god you possess god okay so you need to put a possess god there and while we can say
these things in words it can take a while for us to actually register this in our inner
most being and no one else has entered the divine volition to be able to operate as the
owner with full freedom now it's been perfectly clear for these 16 volumes that louisa is
completely free and jesus still asks her do you want to do it do you do you agree with
complete freedom as if it were his own now when we enter into the divine will when we
fuse in the divine will we have complete freedom to either go and take the precious blood of
the lamb and use that to redeem the world or go in and take his wisdom and give that to
the political and religious leaders or whatever you want you're completely free it's very
interesting to see what people do I should say it would be if you knew because half of
us don't understand the freedom we have and don't realize what you can do with all the
divine attributes and since the thing that's needed most on the planet both with religious
as well as political leaders is wisdom we need to go in take the wisdom of god and actually
give it to them because otherwise this world is going to disintegrate and you operate as
the owner and with full freedom as if it were your own so as to be able to enjoy all of
its power and the goods that it contains my will in me is like the soul to the body look
at this now this is actually very important and if doing my will has been the greatest
grace for the saints because they were only able to do it they weren't able to enter in
do you remember as it entered into them as though by reflections why is it by reflections
because not until Louisa could somebody actually operated that plane what will it what will
it be not only to receive the reflections but to actually enter into it and enjoy all
its fullness this is why the saints of today will surpass the saints of yesterday not that
we're better than them humanly okay it's just that we have the privilege of operating
on a divine level and the saints must be looking at this little crowd and this little room
an absolute marvel how tiny the creatures are and we're a small little group of people
that the world wouldn't look at a second time okay and we have this extraordinary privilege
isn't it amazing so Jesus says now if in order to form the redemption it was necessary that
my humanity and my will have access to the divine will so now for the fulfillment of the
field volunteers to honor as it is in heaven it is also necessary that I open again the
doors of my eternal will and I let another creature enter into it giving her free field
and I let her do from her greatest to her littlest act in the all seeingness immensity
and power of my will so I want to give you their song of songs five eight and song songs
five eight the bride says to the bridegroom or maybe it's the bridegroom who says it to
the bride let's go into the vineyards and let's see how the vineyards are doing and let's
go and help because the vineyards are the vineyards of the Lord and they're all the
souls that need to be helped so in all of her acts but the thing is that in her acts in
the divine will we operate in the all seeingness immensity and power of the divine will as you
enter into it he said and admit your thoughts your words your words your steps your reparations
your pains your love your thanksgivings the supreme volition will coin all your acts now
as we go into the higher volumes this is going to be called divine currency okay will coin
all your acts and they will receive the divine image with the value of divine acts which being
infinite can make up for all reach all and have such ascendancy over the divinity as to
make the supreme will descend upon the earth bring its goods all the goods that it contains
now this is absolutely astonishingly amazing Jesus is using the image of an old coin well
I suppose if you had a British coin it's the same thing it has the image of the monarch
on it and he says that in the ancient world the the the piece of metal whatever it was
had no value unless the head of the monarch was on it and if the head of the monarch was
on it then they registered the value of the thing according to the the weight of the metal
that was in it okay so he's saying that when we enter into the divine will all our acts
turn into these coins because the divine images on them it's not fantastic and therefore they
have value in eternity now people all around us who are very little faith would think you
were mad okay it will happen as to metal either to gold or silver until the image of the king
is coined on it it cannot be given the value of currency but as soon as it's coined it
acquires the value of currency and it circulates throughout the whole kingdom there's no town
or village are important place in which it does not enjoy the prestige of currency and
there's no creature that can live without it whether its metal is vile or precious it
actually doesn't matter as long as the image of the king is impressed on it that's a very
important point it doesn't matter whether our acts are tiny or big the thing that's important
is that the divine image is imprinted on them that's what he's saying so it doesn't matter
whether you're blinking your eye or you're saving the world if I can take two extreme
examples the value is that if the divine image is on that action that's you need to put a
VIP on that one okay and and it as long as the image of the king is impressed on it it runs
throughout the whole kingdom enjoys supremacy overall and makes itself love and respected
by all in the same way everything that the soul does in my will now you need to ring that
word everything that you do it in his will since the divine image is coined on it it
runs through heaven and earth it has supremacy overall it does not refuse to give itself
to whomever wants it and there's no place at which its benefit effects cannot be enjoyed
now how do you save the Muslims in the divine will with your divine acts by sending this
divine currency to them that's all it's actually very simple now while Jesus was saying this
we prayed together and Jesus let my intelligence enter into his will look at what a privilege
she has together we offered to the supreme majesty the homage the glory the submission
and the adoration of all human intelligences that's a VIP we have to actually do this ourselves
at the contact with the supreme will a divine image was impressed on the hum the hummage
you can't say hummages we'll say on the adoration without the s and they diffused over all the
created intelligence like many speaking messengers which place themselves in the order of creation
and all of them as though in relation you don't need the s with the supreme will they
love plurals and but who can say what you could see and understand my most sweet Jesus added
my daughter have you seen only by entering into my will that's fusing only by entering
into my will can this actually happen therefore continue to make your gazes your words your
heart and all the rest of you enter into it and you'll see very surprising things then
after spending more than three hours in the divine will doing what Jesus would tell me
to do and together with him I found myself outside of myself and who can say everything
I feel that my poor intelligence is incapable she said and I got to stop here it's very
very interesting isn't it so now that we've been told what an incredible privilege it
is to operate at this level he's going to bring you down to brass tacks in August the
ninth 1923 and let you know what the human will does and he's absolutely divine teacher
he balances everything so he has you up here and you've been on a 747 and he brings you
right down to earth to let you know that if you get out of that airplane you're going
to fall down okay this is really wonderful I was fusing myself in the holy divine volition
and my sweet Jesus clasping me to himself began to pray together with me and he told me my
daughter the human will has covered the whole atmosphere with clouds now we're not really
at the worst part yet we're only at the clouds in such a way that thick darkness hangs over
all creatures now we know there are clouds and clouds some clouds are nice and fluffy
and they let the light through no problem others are so heavy and black that the whole
place goes dark so he's talking about the human will actually knocking out the light
of the divine will and almost all of them walk limping and groping almost all of them
you're talking about the entire population of the planet he's not talking about any particular
group and each human action that they do without the connection with the divine will
intensifies the darkness okay and man becomes more blind okay I want to give you John 9 40
to 41 Jesus had said at the beginning of John chapter 9 I think it's in verse 2 that
I am the light of the world and anyone who follows me will not be walking in darkness
he took a man who had no eye sockets and he created eyes for him and gave him the ability
to say and describes in Pharisees in rejecting Jesus rejecting this sign rejecting the light
that was coming to them became darker and darker and persecuted the man that was healed
and eventually killed Jesus and at the end of it in verses 40 and 41 they said we're
not blind surely and Jesus said if you were a blind I could heal you which you say you
can see and therefore your sin remains now that's conscious deliberate blindness that's
you're talking about here deliberate blindness they're doing everything without the connection
with the divine will it intensifies the darkness and man becomes more blind the reason why I
gave you that tiny explanation is because that's what's going on around us in society
today the blindness is almost on a daily basis now because the light the sun for the human
will is the divine will without the divine will there is no light for the creature so
that's Ephesians 5,8 and 1 John 1 7 where John tells us to for God's sake walk in the
light okay so let's come back up to the good level again but one who operates praise and
walks in my light that's one John 1 7 walking in the light rises above this darkness and
as the soul operates praise speaks piercing these thick clouds she sends flashes of light
over all the earth that's Matthew 5 14 to 16 letting your light shine Matthew 5 14 to
16 now notice what he has us doing he has us piercing that terrible darkness by fusing
in the divine will and operating in the divine will so a small little bit of light gets out
over the whole earth and diffuse diffuses darkness and if more and more and more of us
do it we can diffuse the darkness altogether so she sends flashes of light over the whole
earth such as to shake those who live down below at the level of their wills preparing
the hearts to receive the light the sun of the divine will so notice that the prayers
we do are disposing others to be able to turn back to God so you're converting them at the
level where conversion is absolutely essential enabling them to see you're preparing the
hearts are disposing the hearts to receive the light the sun of the divine will and this
is why I so much care that you live in my will that you may prepare a heaven of light
which sending continuous flashes of light may dispel this heaven of darkness that the
human will has formed over its head in such a way that by possessing the light of my will
they may love the divine will and my will which is loved may reign upon the earth so I think
that's a wonderful explanation there so I'm going to give you one more and the reason
is it's about our blessed mother it's very long maybe it's too long for this time look
at the clock and tell me if you want me to do it do you want me to do it all of you okay
I just thought it'd be nice because on Saturday we'd be talking about our blessed lady okay
so this August the 13th 1923 our blessed lady is the seed of the divine will on the earth
okay so Louisa said I felt oppressed because of the privation of my sweet Jesus and I began
to pray praying him to no longer delay his return to my poor soul but I couldn't endure
anymore and then to my surprise I saw that he was clinging to my neck now that's song
of songs to six surrounding me with his arms and with his face touching mind that's very
touching isn't it and with the light that he wanted to infuse in my mind and as though
drawn I kissed him and it was as if I wanted to reject that light saying to myself I love
this this is a temptation at a higher level if you want to know how the saints are tempted
this is it she said no she has Jesus in her arms she has everything yes just kissed her
and she's kissed him this is it she says I don't care about knowing things I don't I
only want to save my soul and Jesus alone is enough for me everything else is nothing after
all the trouble he's gone to try and reveal about the divine will turn and all the disposing
offer to come to this point she says no no I'm not interested in anything now that's
the temptation at a very high level okay and as Jesus touched my forehead oh oh look where
he's touching okay I could resist no more and the light entered into me saying my daughter
one who has been called to an office she's been called to the office of opening the doors
of the kingdom of the divine will on the earth most know the secrets the importance the duties
the goods the founder and everything that pertains to that office otherwise you can't really
have the office now you must know that a simple creature broke the relations which existed
between the divine will and humanity so that's Adam this split destroyed the plans that the
divinity had in the creation of man now another simple creature though endowed with many graces
and privileges but still a mere creature the virgin queen of all was given the office to
bind again to cement I like that word and to place herself in relation doesn't need the
s with the will of her creation in order to repair the first split of that first creature
a woman the first a woman the second the first one that broke was Eve the one who binds
is also a woman but it's also going to bring Louisa in as well she was precisely the one
who by binding her will to ours gave back to us the honor the decorum the subjection and
the rights of creation was it not one creature that received the beginning of evil and formed
the seed of the ruin of all generations now that lady is Eve in the same way this celestial
creature all by herself received the beginning of good by placing herself in relation with
the will of her creator she placed the seed of the eternal fear and this is very important
this is the first time we're seeing this okay and nb at the side won't be any harm she
formed the seed of the eternal fear which was to be the salvation the sanctity and the
well being of all the seed is the very first thing you plant in the ground okay now as this
celestial creature kept growing so did the seed of the eternal fiat grow in her and as
this seed became a tree in other words mature the eternal word first felt captured to rest
in the shade of his eternal volition and was conceived forming his humanity in that
virginal room in which his supreme will reigned as ruling king now I think it's very interesting
that the divine will is referred to as the tree of life usually Jesus himself is referred
to as the tree of life okay but we had it in an earlier volume as well do you see then
how all goods descend from my supreme will and all evils enter the field when the creature
withdraws from the divine will had I not found a creature who had my will as life and who
placed herself in relation with me with with those bonds of creation wanted by me I would
not have wanted nor been able to descend from heaven and to take on human flesh in order
to save them so my mother was the beginning you need an envy here the beginning the origin
the seed of the Fiat Balantas tour and heaven and on earth as it is in heaven since one creature
had destroyed it it was just that another creature would rebuild it look at the detail
that the Lord does instead of just wiping something out and starting all over again he
wants the detail of the picture recreated it is very very interesting and my humanity
he said which never separated from my divinity upon this seed of my own will which I found
in the divine mother I formed the great plane of the human will in the divine now a plane
according to the dictionary is a level of existence I formed this new level of existence
where the human will could actually operate in the divine will so with my human will united
to the divine there was no human act that I did that I did not place in relation to
the supreme volition with the divine will I was aware of all the acts of all generations
colored on what an unbelievable burden to carry wouldn't it be an unbelievable to carry
all the acts of everybody in this country let alone any other country let alone all creatures
an incredible burden with the human will I kept repairing them he said and I bound them
to the eternal volition this is the redoing of the human person ok this is the redoing
of humanity there was not one act which could escape me and which was not ordered by me
in the most pure light of the supreme will I could say that redemption cost me little
my eternal life the pains of my passion my example need don't need the s my word would
have been sufficient and it could have been over quickly but in order to form the great
plane of the human will in the divine this new level of existence of the human will in
the divine and to bind all the relations and links which had been broken by it I had to
place my whole interior my whole hidden life and all my intimate pains which were far more
numerous and more intense than my external pains and which are not yet known you'll get
to know about them much more as you go on it's enough to say that it was not just forgiveness
that I interceded for it was remission of sins refuge escape defense in all the great dangers
of life of man as I did my passion but it was the new rising of the whole interior of
man now Louisa brings this out in the crowning of Jesus with thorns in the hours of the passion
that Jesus made reparation for the fall of the intellect memory and will the three great
powers of the soul and so he paid for the resurrection of the intellect memory and will
with the crown of thorns so that's the rising of the interior okay of humanity I think it's
very important for us to keep repeating that all the time this is the resurrection to grace
of the human race and we can't have the new Jerusalem at the other end of history without
this that the resurrection to grace has got to happen I had to make the sun of the eternal
will rise which binding his whole his is the humanity his whole interior within rapturing
power even his most intimate fibers would lead him into the womb of my celestial father as
though reborn to his eternal will that is reborn to resurrection and glory but it's on this
earth it's not after death you see before divine will we all knew that the resurrection
was after death but with the divine will the resurrection is now okay and each time we
fuse in the divine will and do our acts in the divine will every single one of them is
a step into resurrection and glory every single one and that's what encourages people to do
more and more of them oh how much easier it was for me Jesus said to impotrate man's salvation
than to reorder his interior in my supreme volition just taking that you have rare children and you
know how extremely difficult it is to get someone to change their mind about something even if
they're completely wrong and even if they know they're completely wrong it's still very difficult
to do it because human beings are very stubborn holding on to their own opinion and their own
position so can you know you can't imagine I won't ask you can you imagine how did Jesus try and get
to do that for the whole of humanity for all time I mean the pain must be something that is
completely incomprehensible to us the price that he would have to pay okay so how much easier it was
for me to impotrate his salvation than to reorder his interior in my supreme volition and had I not
done this redemption would not have been complete nor a work worthy of God don't put a knock out the
A it's not English I would have either neither balanced nor ordered all the accounts of man nor
would I have I restored him to that sanctity which he had lost by withdrawing from the divine will and
by breaking his relations with it the plane is already done this new level of existence of the
human will in the divine is already done Jesus has done it but in order to make it known first it
was necessary for man to know that with my life and passion he could obtain forgiveness and salvation
they're the first steps of the letter in order to dispose him to know how I had impotrated for him
the highest and the most important thing the new rising this is spiritual resurrection the new rising
of his will in mind and that's why he says that for somebody who has finally entered the divine will
24 7 365 and is not leaving it at all he says it's a new baptism that it's you have you've actually
risen from the dead and so I impotrated the earlier things in order for him to receive the most
important thing the new rising of his will in mind to give back to him his nobility
and the relations with my will which had been broken and with it his state of origin
now my daughter if my eternal wisdom disposed that one celestial creature the holiest of all
would prepare the seed of my holy will which I had in which I had formed the plane of the new
rising of man in my supreme will now through another creature by letting her enter the eternal
dwellings of my will and binding her will to mine this is Louisa uniting her to all my acts
I make her whole interior rise again in the eternal sun of my will opening the field of this
plane this new level of existence opening it up to all generations Louisa had to allow it to happen
in her first and then he opens it up to all generations just as redemption started through blessed mother
and then completed by Jesus and then it's opened up to everybody else but she had to receive the
whole of redemption first Louisa has to receive the whole of the divine will first
and then you open up this new level of existence to all generations so that whoever wants it can
enter into it to place himself in relation to the will of God so notice the little bit that you read
in Tony's little booklet is if you want it I'll do it now all we have to do is actually want to go
into it and if until now souls have enjoyed the goods of redemption now they will move further to
enjoy the fruits of the fiat volontas tour on earth as it is in heaven I don't know why they
don't finish that in latin all the time it doesn't make sense to me to put it half latin and half
England he said what is being restored to them is that lost happiness that's paradise regained
paradise is the human person in union with the divine
that lost happiness that dignity and nobility that peace all celestial now that celestial peace
is Philippians 4 7 the peace that passes all understanding and guards the heart and the mind
in Christ Jesus and also Isaiah 62 3 Isaiah 62 3 you will keep him in perfect peace whose mind
is stayed on you so that peace all celestial which by doing his will man had caused to disappear
from the face of the earth now you can observe with very little effort that the more our society
moves away from God's will the more un peaceful they are the more belligerent the more angry the
more upset the more dark the more disturbed they are and it's obvious you don't have to even go
very far to see it because it's everywhere around us and what they've lost is that
paradisical happiness at the dignity and nobility that God gave to us and the peace that passes all
understanding greater grace Jesus said I could not give humanity because by placing man again in
relation with my will I give back to him all the goods with which I endowed him in creating him
therefore be attentive because this is about opening a large field of goods for all your brothers in
other words this is about opening a new era I think that's a good place to stop